um
hello hello
i hope someone can hear me
um
i just need to quickly access the chat
so i can even see you because i
forgot but if you're here welcome
it's this is nothing special
we're just thank you we're just going to
uh quickly
jump into the ark game
hi
thanks for letting me know
so the arc challenge is this game i
don't know if you've seen that
uh
so
you're given kind of these boards and
there's always an input and an output
and
so the left one is always the input the
right side is always the output by the
way this is um by
by alexa borski a nice website the arc
game you can find it on github and a
link to it so the left side is the input
the right side is the output and you are
supposed to
do the pattern
you know recognize the pattern from left
to right from left to right from left to
right so this one is an easy one it's
basically
the rule as you can see is there's
always twice the same thing like next to
each other or here on top of one another
and you are required to fill out this
test sample right here so i guess we can
do that actually if you click on the
left thing it will actually copy it over
to the right side which just happens to
be the uh the perfect solution here but
you can you know fill in anything you
want right here if we did it manually
we would do it like this
like this so i'll just copy like the top
part here
this
and like this and you can check whether
you get it correct and we got it correct
okay very nice actually i should
probably so let me obs
uh let me put some sort of a banner
right here
of what we're doing
no ah you cannot win a 30 90 at this
time so
we
are solving arc
cool
uh yeah
so
arc challenge is this thing all of these
are really simple for humans but really
tough for machines
so um here
you see and you can't even formulate it
right there's just kind of there's lines
so you're kind of supposed to just take
the color
that is not the lines maybe
i guess so we'll just all fill all of
this with blue
and we got it correct nice so they get
from from simple uh to quite hard so um
yeah
you can check it out for yourself the
data set has about 400
training example and every single
example
is um you have a link to arc yes sorry
yeah i should probably so there's
there's different things i'll just i'll
put a link i'll put a link to i'll put a
link to this thing um
yeah i'll put a link here
so
yeah these are these go from easy to to
to super hard but for humans they're
never hard but for machines as you can
imagine they're quite hard and every one
of them uses kind of like a different uh
notion so there's not twice
there is rarely twice the same kind of
logic behind how you solve these games
um
i've never tried google's fubar coding i
don't even know what that is i'm sorry
uh
it's been a long time since i've done
actual coding challenges however uh we
at our discord have decided to give this
a little bit of a shot so
we have
i should probably
um i think this is public
github.com
arc community maybe
yeah exactly so
there you can see a bunch of of repos
and we've just started so my goal in
this repository right here is to provide
a little bit of a framework
um
a little bit of a framework or of
evaluating these things
and i got pretty far so far so the idea
is that
i have a test right here
the idea is that you
would implement
an agent so an agent is this thing
and the agent implements a method called
solve test sample
and there you get a list of training
samples these are these three samples or
so and you get a test board and you're
supposed to output top k list of
solutions top k list is simply
a list of boards so you're supposed to
output boards
you can make use of these hints right
here although
you will not get any points in the final
result if you do but for start that's
that you can use that the task data
simply contains the top k
that you're supposed to output so it's
pretty pretty simple and you're simply
you simply need to implement this method
and then the goal here is that i then
take your agent and evaluate it on the
data set give it a nice report and so on
um so that you can try yourself like how
would you go about programming an
algorithm that can solve these types of
tasks which is really hard especially
there's only 400 training examples as i
said
and 400 test examples and none no two
examples use the same logic
you just need to generalize from like
the essentially the in-context learning
right here and yes you could use a large
language model uh for this but
gpt 4chan made you notorious meaning i
wasn't notorious before
no yeah that was quite something but
we're back to family friendly stuff no
one absolutely no one's gonna complain
about collary squares right so this is
completely controversy free that's why
it's a good good project
so
this is here is an implementation of a
cheating agent so the cheating agent
as i said you can use these hints right
here and one of the hints is actually
the output and the output will just give
you the solution right so the cheating
agent actually looks at the output and
just returns that and
you know good enough and um
in fact
it will be recorded in the hints that
you actually access that so we'll have
that in the evaluation
so the goal now that i have today is to
finish this setup of this evaluation
code so people can actually use it
productively let's say i already have
code to download the data set and so on
but i'm having a bit of trouble um how
it when it comes to metrics so metrics
in my mind is this thing and
we can look at it
so a metric
could be like accuracy accuracy is like
or correctness whether or not you solved
a sample correctly that's kind of the
most basic metric but there can be more
metrics right there can be um how much
of the pixels you got correct and so on
so these aren't counted in the end
you know
you only get a point if you get it
exactly correct however they can tell
you something about
the progress you're making
so my idea of a metric is it has two
methods one is compute and you would
give that a single result right a single
evaluation result
you give to the metric it will produce
something for example right
did you solve the riddle correctly
and
the aggregate function then would
aggregate this across all
of essentially across all of the um
evaluation results all of the riddles so
one metric that i implemented here is
the
correctness metric as you can see right
here so this would compute
over the
all the test examples of one riddle the
minimum value so did you get essentially
you get one if you get all the riddles
correct
and it would then aggregate across all
of them in a mean fashion so
the result of this metric would be how
many
or what fraction of riddles of the data
set did you get correctly that's it
um
now
so far what i've done is i have
implemented these as property of the
evaluation result you can see here is
the evaluation result that's con that's
constructed
uh
as your agent outputs a solution this is
you know done and here i have metrics
results in it and i don't really like it
i think the metric you should be able to
save the evaluation result and then
compute maybe the metric even later on
that evaluation result so we're going to
rip out the metrics results from here
and the aggregation results from this
eval result list which i also construct
and then
hopefully hopefully
um yeah how good is this the state of
the art on arc i believe it's really
weak like it's certainly below 20
or so or 30
solved
or or even even weaker like it is it is
quite weak uh there is not a good
algorithm yet and it has some some
properties right you actually need to
you need to hard code human priors that
that's actually it's in the paper
so
yeah it's tough um
all right so i'm gonna rip essentially
out these metrics results right here and
i'm going to manage the metrics results
externally
so let's say so here we have
yeah no
no
okay
so here is a metric and the metric we
can actually also rip out uh into its
own file
let's say we
yeah into the metrics file why not
so we have a metric right here
like that
and
oopsie
is the eval result in the interface yes
okay so we'll import that we already
have it okay uh
and we need that
the eval result here cannot be a string
anymore
okay
i mean this is this is already good
enough can you share you set up the vim
rc
um so yeah the the ide is
neovim
um and i am currently really strongly
considering redoing my vmrc
so first i want to use the the lua
configuration of neovim and i want to
like get different different plugins
because these have become quite a mess
you will also see if you watch me code
that pirate like the loading bar is
currently going all the time and stuff
so it's it's really become not good and
jumbled so i'll uh redo it and once i've
redone it and i'm actually proud of the
setup then i can i can maybe share it
but i'm using relatively standard
plugins i'm also using coc i'm using
copilot
and
yum
i don't actually know if copilot works
in this
because i'm using python 3 9 and neovim
complained anyway
so we get compute and aggregate and so
the um
yeah the problem here a little bit is
well
yeah uh i will make these actually
underscore functions because
we can then track
so a pattern that i like to use often
is anything wrong with vs code it's not
vim that's that's kind of the the only
thing
[Music]
so
you know
um
okay
and
good
i know this seems pointless but it is
not
[Laughter]
because
because
yeah it is not pointless because you can
give users kind of the opportunity to
override this but you still have a hook
into it right with the non-underscore
functions uh as a framework developer
it's an interesting pattern that i think
makes sense a lot of times if you want
to give people you know the opportunity
to sub class things and you can still do
logging and track access and so on in
the non-underscore function especially
here uh we now have the opportunity to
instead of this give the
eval results
list
no i missed by one
okay see it's too it's kind of slow so
yeah
so now here we have to so out of the
eval results list we have to fish out
no actually yeah so now now we get into
trouble right
let's say we just cancel this for now
and we make these into underscores
so
when we eval something we have a result
and then we want to compute the metric
on it and that gives us a metrics result
right and in that case it's any now i'm
going to play around with the typing or
something
but
but in our case it's just kind of any so
that's just a
result
we need to store that result
somehow in a data structure so let's go
over to the eval
here
so here we have apply
metrics
and
yeah so
what we'll do is we'll go
see now there's the problem we'll go by
metric by metric
we'll go through all the results what
are your thoughts on the minerva model i
have not i will read the paper as soon
as possible
uh but i'm really trying to get this
done so the community can actually use
this code
but it's it's super cool and
i think that so i've read it a little
bit but not in detail but my opinion so
far is
is data quality is really king right
there there they just parse
i've this is not i've also talked to
some people about it and it seems like
how well you can parse pdfs and stuff
and and lottek
is a big part of
of your data quality and your data
quality directly influences the results
so
better take good good care of your data
right
right it actually pays to pays off to to
clean your data well and pre-process it
well and so on seems to be a real boost
all right so now we're going through
every result so
ah
for eval result actually we can we can
just use we can just ask copilot here
see
uh
metric result
okay so
we get a result for each of these and we
can probably make this into a list
comprehension actually because
um
metric dot compute
like this
so that's metric
results
so for every riddle we now have a result
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to give that to the um to the
aggregation function
so metric dot aggregate
now it depends on how we've implemented
this right
let's go over to the metric
and
so what do we have here we have the eval
results and we also need a list of
metrics results
metric results these are the things that
have been computed by compute above
list
any for now
it's not pretty
it's not pretty but
you know
that's that's what we get
um
yes
i think that's that we can also have
that exact same
interface right here
and we can just replicate this here
i'm not even
it's reckless to not check co-pilot
output but sometimes you're just so
confident that
you can just give it to get to co-pilot
all right
so now we what we need is a data
structure
that keeps all of this stuff right
um
again we're going to probably go to
metric and we are going to make
we'll need pydantic
if you don't know pedantic very good
library
like data classes except cooler metric
result
yeah why not let's call it metric
results so
uh it's yeah it's like data classes but
nicely serializable nice print functions
and to json from json and so on and and
with validators
really nice
things
so
the metric result here
now
the only issue i have a little bit is
the task has several riddles right and
and they're just in a list
now the metrics results also obviously
you'll get a list of results
the question is can we just simply like
have two lists and sort of implicitly be
like well the first element is the first
element and the second corresponds to
the second that's really not very nice
but i don't know like we would need to
make everything into like a dick
um
that's also not particularly
sorry particularly
um
nice so
hmm
i think i'll just stick with the list so
i'm going to say
uh
eval
[Music]
okay how are we calling these
uh
let's call them riddle
results
and
this is a list
and these and this is like
aggregation result
okay
now let's call that compute results
because the method is compute
and
aggregate results
result
and we'll still need to do something
about that any but i will have to read
the python documentation
[Music]
um
on typing
to to really see how we can do this with
inheritance and so on because the idea
is
that you could define your output type
here
and then you the type checker could make
sure that you'll get the same thing for
now it's just any i'm i'm sorry okay
i know you can do type var but i don't
know how that behaves
with
inheritance
although
i think
you could
hear
you should be able to do something
and then have that show up
can we
okay maybe we'll
we'll do this
um
all right
and generics
generic
generic
aha okay okay
so
a generic type
is from an instantiation of this class
yes
generic
okay
must be a subtype of something
[Music]
we could do this right we could have
inherit from generic
and then we could
yeah okay um
from typing
generic
and then here we'd have
generic t
now t isn't known so we also need to
type var
t equals type for
metric
type
what's wrong with that
okay um
let's just do it let's just say it's t
so we can have all of these be t t t t
right
okay
and then we need to
just take care that here
so now i'm wondering
here this is a float
and then we get a float right here
right
and this here is
also float
but
i'm feeling like a a duper super
programmer
and obviously ah okay pedantic and
generics do they play well
do they do they go with one another
let's check it out
i'm not sure
but
okay okay i see the problem
interesting
yes we're doing
we're doing api stuff
generics from java
yeah
java is a mess especially generics
however
generic models there we go
generic models are only supported that's
fine that's fine too that's okay
so
here
we have generic model
generic data
okay seems like we
have
to
we have to inherit from generic model
um
can we do that
you see the yeah pyrite is going
and
generic t
and then here we get a t
i'm still not
super satisfied
because
because um
well how about we have aggregate
actually output
the result
right
like that
um
like this
and
well here we can't have metric results
we'll need to
call it compute results too
sorry i'm neglecting chat are we doing
api stuff yes we're doing api stuff
um hopefully hopefully
compute results compute results now
we're ready to
everything's called result
socket naming things
so
yes
yes
yes thank you co-pilot that is quite
nice of you
okay
all right
so the compute method
is fine here is all fine all good
and the aggregate method
is fine
and now we simply need to implement we
would have to change the definition
of this aggregate right here
so
here we have a class doing mean
aggregation
if you see
this this needs to be a float obviously
if it's some sort of a mean
and
yeah that's it um
if not okay
yep
yep
yep
can you plug co-pilot in vim as yes tim
pope himself actually wrote the copilot
plugin and does not accept pull requests
currently so
but yeah exactly
get value where do i have this get value
gives a float i think this is fine
luckily
oopsy
luckily i have
written tests
let's see how that goes
that that is good very good very very
excellent
what do you mean
what could not be does it but it says
here oh generics
okay
all right
nope
generics
there we go
okay now our problem is that in eval
we can't
import metric that makes sense
do we need it we actually need it okay
good
and
metric compute
eval result eval result
tuple is not compatible
oh no see now we get into typing typing
issues
so we're in the eval results list
which is
we actually need to access eval results
eval result
list
dot eval results
actually we could just extract that here
like this
and we're pretty good i think
let's see
wow that's slow
all right that's better
so
this has no attribute oh oops
this is no attribute aggregation results
um
okay
aggregate
i i called it aggregate result
um
yeah so now
the tricky part is
yeah we are not done by a long shot
uh
see here
i say apply metrics okay this applies
the metrics now
what's it what what is it going to do
it's going to call compute and that is
fine
or trying to make an api for metric eval
yes exactly so i'm trying to write code
for other people to use to evaluate
their their agents on the ark challenge
if you're new here the arc challenge is
uh
is uh
uh
this thing
this yes
so
we are here and we then call aggregate
aggregate takes the results list and the
results from compute
so we'll actually rename that to
compute results
we'll rename that to eval result list
and we'll get a metric result
out of that
so now
we get
a result per metric
now the metric result
the metric itself has a name
therefore the metric result should
probably also have a name
that makes a lot of sense
um
yeah
yes it does it does make a lot of sense
so good
all right
the metric result now has a name
and
metric
results
ta-da we'll add that to the list we'll
return that list
we'll say here that is
a list of metric
result
a metric result will import from
here
all right so now we just need to
um what's the console text editor this
is neovim which is very slow because i'm
streaming i have the camera as like an
external camera feed over an hdmi i have
a second screen that is streaming to the
ipad
uh
and i'm running copilot and
this is an api but i'm running a pyrite
language server in the background so
this thing is stressed
uh but it it works it's fine um
and my hard disk is almost full
which i figured is is not good like if
you're below 10
things get slow
need to clean up all right um
[Music]
we'll have the eval test right here so
this thing now
if you apply metrics you should get a
list of these metric results right which
correspond to
um
or these these metrics here
so
the issue is
it's just a list
how would you explain the reasoning of
the correct answer to a kid that failed
the question yeah that is it's really
it's like you can't
um like a lot of times uh it is just
human intuition e type of things so
here for example
look at that so
there's just like
the lower left
or the top right thing goes to red and
the lower left things go to blue
now
that
contains so many human assumptions like
you know what what is a thing what is an
object right we recognize these same
color thing as the object and maybe we
recognize even the the back black pixels
as the background but to an algorithm
there's no objects there's just pixels
and there's no things and there's no
inherent separation and so on no
come on
what
what
that is mad
what'd i do wrong
i'm right
[Laughter]
see i don't even i don't even like i
don't know what's wrong
uh i'm pretty sure this is no oh come on
well we'll have to live with with
failing this one
the bigger ones
are red
ah maybe it's the smallest the smallest
one
that's um
or the one that no
is
or the one that taught no
is codepal good or bad it's very good
smallest is red okay let's try let's try
that i'll make this blue
and i'll make this
red
all right good job good job chat robbie
encode the whole thing with clip then
test the similarity will not work
well prop no not gonna say it's not work
will probably not work because
clip is trained very much on natural
images it like the the capability of
like abstracting to like
ob seeing objects in these types of of
things is very hard
um the challenge seems similar to the
measure of intelligence paper
uh yeah it's actually from that paper
the last chapter in that paper describes
this challenge
so yeah
a different object is different that
could have been it too yes
all right so
the issue right now is we have a metric
result right
um
but we will just get a list
so i would like to have
i would like to have
i would like to have like a
thing
maybe i'll just return a dick but
you it's it's good to have some sort of
a type
so we'll say
we'll say
a metrics result
matrix
dict
is addict
that goes from a string to
a metric result
right and we'll put that down here
yup
i guess that's cool
so what we can then do and we actually
don't need the any anymore that's good
it's always a good sign
so in eval what we can do
instead of just having a list right here
we can have a matrix result ticked
we can instantiate that here
um
and we can
not append
but
um
at that here
cool
and then this is no longer a list but
this is now a
addict
that seems fine
so now the last thing we'll actually
need is we'll need to create a kind of
like a unified package of all of this so
we now have
um
metrics that we
call
right
and
i think what we should do last is
some sort of
report right
so let's
call that reports
um
yeah
why not
report
okay
user
bin and
python
um
we'll make it pedantic
report
base model
okay
and
all right so
the report
is going to be generated by
eval
so what do we need in a report on this
thing let's make this a bit bigger so
you all can see
oopsie
hey this crashed all right
um
let's split it
so we'll certainly need the eval result
list right
um
yeah
so from
interface
import eval result list
then we need these metrics results so
import
um
metric result dict
matrix
metric result
dick
yes
okay
then
what do we need
we may need
like what data set was used maybe
maybe
who knows
um
let's consider eval again
we may need a date time like
can we do that um
so
yeah we can do that right
hmm
sure why not
this top of the screen is cut off oh i'm
sorry
that is
how about this
or this
yeah better
[Music]
a bit more
yeah so a date time to to check when the
report was generated
um do we do we want to call this like
metadata or so
maybe not uh
import
date time
so
um
how about this
field with a default factory
oh
okay now it's
trying to get it right i think this is
okay
cool yep um
[Music]
we can give it
i don't know
tags
uh
[Music]
how about
oh yeah the data set maybe that is also
a good thing so
um i have a dataset utils class right
here
and
um
these sub dears
let's say
sub dears
list of string
and we'll also
we'll also
comment maybe
comment
string
something like this right something that
packages all of these things together
and then
uh
and then saves it down so these are all
either pedantic models or standard
models
so we are going to
and this one doesn't even have to be
here
all we need is the eval results really
and
now we have we can have various methods
to actually render this
or
yeah so we can have various
representations of that however
i'm not sure if i want to implement stir
right here
would
augmenting
tag the screen would stream with asmr
okay
uh would augmenting example with natural
descriptions help maybe i don't know
could you create a program to
procedurally generate similar puzzles
with a text label to train on like an
l or an i system then learn to generate
the text from the samples results from
the text yeah probably i mean
if you can come up with text
descriptions but again there's 400 test
examples which is not too many so
a lot of deep learning
type of things are out of the question
at least without
help but generating
data is one of the things one of the
routes we are considering yes but
the question is how because
you know you need to build in these
human priors like gravity and objectness
and so on
so
i don't want to um
let's
save to file
uh
file name
no no no we'll go
os
so
all of this um
from path lib
import path
we'll make this a path like
very good thanks copilot
so this saves the report to a file
now
the eval here
it currently evaluates agents on riddle
and on riddles it applies metrics now we
need a function
that um
well it's a good question
what we now need is a function how can i
improve my coding skills
have you heard of bit tensor
um
i have heard of it my current opinion is
that is buzzwords but i i've not looked
into it very clearly
i hear there is an interview on towards
data science
but i've not listened to it
how can i improve my coding skills just
code and look at other people's code and
submit pull requests to stuff and take
the feedback
with a grain of salt but take it
seriously um
[Music]
or or join a company
that has some good standards or
something
or look at
coding guidelines from big companies
because
you know they for for for some reason
they have survived and that's a
challenge
if you code with a lot of people
so they need good standards
all right so
we now
need
we now need
a last function
that
does everything
you know
uh
maybe at once nah i'm not sure
that loads kind of loads
so if we load the data set we say
evaluate we say apply metrics and then
we ship this all in we we shove it all
into report
um
that should technically
you know do all the things
but we could do it in the cli
yes probably we should do it in that cli
so there's a cli uh by the way i'm i'm
really proud of the cli so you can do
something like so if you type arc
that's the cli if you've installed the
thing so
you can do help
you can do arc
show
random id
it will show you one of the tasks that's
a bit of a big task but
maybe i zoom out
for
see it will show you like a random id
uh puzzle
which is pretty cool and then you can
try to solve it
this is all in console
that's why it's especially cool
so um
yeah we need
one thing that evaluates
an agent on a data set
and that's going to be
the kind of last thing
um
now the question is can i load an agent
from
can i load an agent from this so eval
can we import the data set thing from
from eval because
probably probably
um
clip happens to know physics
he also fears its own mortality
no not clip
but yeah that was that was a fun
certainly a fun
fun thing
um
i'm just
trying to think how
we best do this
uh
how about we make an example
so
let's make
not here let's make
examples
like that out here
actually let's move that into a
directory called examples
so
we'll take that
cheating agent maybe i should
maybe i should move this
um
to this
like
base
like that seems pretty good and
then we can do an init file right
and just import the agent
from
import agent
we'll all it out
good
all right and then we can have um
the cheating agent inside of this one
so let's go to the eval test
rip out the cheating agent like this
put it in here
from
agent
um
import task data
or
hints
board pair
board
help k list
i think we have it now
port hints isn't exported oh that's from
hints maybe
i guess we we need to export all of
these from arc anyway
challenge seems to be solvable with only
low level priors but high level prices
sequence of translation with reasoning
is made up of more primitive priors
yes but also the com like there's not an
arbitrary combination that's also one of
the challenging things
so i don't i don't really know how to
yeah so we should be able to import all
of these from arc i think
like this
so let's make that happen
here
yeah from
import agent
task data
uh we'll also need from
import
board hints
um
hints certainly will also need the top k
list
right here
i hope that's enough
good
all right
so this cheating agent
as i said is able to just look at
from arc import star no no no no no no
bad didn't someone ask how can i improve
my coding not like not with star imports
although sometimes it's it's just quick
i think
yeah
especially if you're
if you want to do something quick so the
cheating agent uh will import that then
in the eval test right here
because we can
we don't need any of these anymore
except task data
um
from arc dot
yep
i need to
restart whenever i make a new file i
need to restart like that that's dumb
something's wrong with my setup clearly
so does this still run
see how slow this is
it's terribly slow
yup has no
aggregation results yeah so now is the
part where we have to actually change
the test
so here is the metrics
yep
here we have the eval results i would
call that
result list
um
apply the metrics
yes that was give you'll give us a
metric
result
dict
um
[Music]
yep
and
how about that
garbage collector yeah maybe
ah okay i need to
[Music]
aggregate result
yes
hopefully
good test passes
wow
um
let's look at it okay
come
commit
uh
metrics
okay now we need like a last function
that that just generates the report from
the riddles and then maybe one that also
loads the data set
sorry and then we're good
again
okay any an interface
ah yeah i see
go go go go go go
excellent okay ship it
and yeah we'll go on so
let's go to eval
let's
um evaluate
agent
on
riddles
no
no how do we call this i want to take
something that's
takes
riddles
metrics
and generates a report
essentially it's just going to call the
things above so it'd be evaluate agent
on riddles and apply metrics and
generate report
uh
no
um
is hard it's hard
report
from riddles
that's not too bad
all right
let's do this um
evaluate r3
uh
and
matrix
so essentially we'll do the exact same
thing as we did before
no if not the evaluate on radios
report from riddles
that
yes
yes
yes no not matrix results i want a
report
apply metrics
um
the report
does it have uh
how about instead because we
we'll just call that eval results
metric
results
that should be good
all right return
report
i know results
evaluate and report that is that that is
that is a
good good name
very good name
evaluate
evaluate on riddles
good
here i want evaluate on
data set and report so instead of
riddles
we'll take
subdirectories
no actually that that's that's fine
that's just good enough
very good
biometrics has everything it needs good
nice
alright so
format it
good
now we can
[Music]
i still don't know how we should get the
agent now in there but we can make an
example this
we can
rewrite the eval test right here
um
to this so
let's have
uh
yup
this
that
actually yeah let's just
say evaluate and report
and let's rename it
good idea very good idea what plugins
are using i don't know i've lost
overview myself so
you know
[Laughter]
um and
that should probably optionally take
metrics right
because uh
no let's do it right if matrix is
none
yep
um
yep
cool
we don't need apply metrics this will do
it all
so
[Music]
yep
okay
now the one thing i think we also need
is we'll need some default metrics right
um
get default metrics
and that
should give us a list of metrics
and that would return yeah why not these
two
so here we can actually instead of this
we can say
default metrics
because most people are just going to
use the
default metrics
test it again
and good so i have about more five five
to ten more minutes of time
and i'm going to use that to
probably make
an example
and the example is going to be pretty
much just the the test
so
here is the example
um
ah
[Music]
copilot go
go thank you
arc agents
cheating
important cheating agent
will
from
arc.metrics import
default metrics
and
um
[Music]
evol
so oh yeah the riddles yes now
what we'll actually need is also the
data set from
utils
maybe we should the evaluate and report
maybe we could
export that somehow
in arc
because it's it might be very common
right so
like this
[Music]
good
um
okay
the task data
how do we know if it's not a bot and
co-pilot
um
yeah we'll need
get
riddles
from
the training subdirectory that's fine
okay
and the task data let's say
top k
is
three
um
correct fraction
now this is going to be one hopefully
let's try it out
let's go to examples
let's
try it
and we'll see
we should probably have some sort of
um
indicator of the progress and stuff
i think that would be
be something no
well correct fraction one
um yeah so do we have a logger already
from
three months ago he looked more jacked
that is true that is actually true i
have not had time
to work out too much
uh was busy getting cancelled so
um
um
info
evaluating agent
on some riddles
let's spin here
evaluate agent on riddles
ah this goes up here probably that's
better
um
let's put in some tucodum here
do we have it in the requirements
do we have it in the setup
we have it good
so
where was i
just now
there we go
um
all right
let's see how that works
nice
does wearing shades make you a better
code
didn't know vim had auto complete
functions it's plugins it's all it's
language servers
um
downloading
get
where
get riddles so here
all right that should do
then the last thing applying metrics
how about this
let's try
we're loading the data set very nice
evaluating very nice loading bar
excellent
now
the
apply metrics correct
apply metric board size correct fraction
1. we should probably
good
and that
is a really nice example
it's pretty simple if you ask me
and then you can store that to some file
if you want
and you can probably also implement your
own agent
but that's a task for another day
so i
yeah
added example
isn't it hard to see yes especially if
they're polarized so if i do this i
can't see anything
but you know
so in case anyone is interested in
solving the arc challenge this is
currently our community project on our
discord which i hope you'll find if not
it's like why culture dot com slash
discord
um
in case you're interested i will be
pushing all this code soon and i'll also
make
a bit of a
i'll make more examples on how you can
exactly interact with this but
ultimately you can you'll also be able
to use the the cli
for it
and
yeah and i'll make the reports do
prettier outputs
and
that will be that
i think that will go right here you'll
be able to load some sort of data set
um
hopefully
probably
yes
you'll be able to load some sort of data
set generate a report
what is it yes this is a library that
you can use to evaluate your agents what
i don't know yet is how do apps like
flask and so on um or uv corn
you're given you give them like a file
name right and they dynamically seem to
load
whatever is in the file name so uh
uh crap how how can we look this up
python
dynamically load
class from
file by file name or something
import from dynamic file name yeah see
i have a python script
config file yes exactly so that is my
problem
the import module
to dynamic import modules this is what
we need
so this
um i'll make it a bit bigger
ah
cool
so
import module and then get adder
hey this isn't too hard we could do that
we could totally do that
um
okay let's try let's try we got five
minutes um
so
we'll make a command
this is
eval
let's just call that
yes
um
and that's going to take
how should we how should we do this um
that's going to take like
agent
i then agent
path or something
no
i want something like flask has so let's
just do this a string
yeah it's not it's not particularly
good
it's not a particularly good interface
yet
but
um
hmm
i'm not i'm not a fan of it yet
sub dear
i'm not a fan of it yet
how about we just do this for now
so what i want to do is i want to
agent file path agent
class name
is
as we split it
by this
so you would be able to do hopefully you
would be able to do
um
arc
eval
and then you'd say something like
arc
or agents
um
cheating agent
dot
cheating agent
like this right
and
use import lib
yeah exactly that's pretty good
we'll do it
so
import import module
ah but it needs to be
in path so we can't actually do this
right here
we'll have to do
we'll have to do well this is super
duper slow
like this
yes yes yes
good
uh
agent module name
okay
agent class
very good
i co-pilot is doing all of this for me
really there's nothing nothing i need to
do um
and now i need to to evaluate it right
so um
import evaluate and report so i'll get
my
i'll get my
uh
data set
get riddles
and we'll get like
we'll make later parameters but
report equals evaluate and report
no that's just the function
evaluate and report takes agent riddles
task data and metrics
riddles
so
um
arc import task data
and
get default metric that's probably also
something we should put into arc itself
no
i think so
yes
yes
good um
[Music]
okay
again
what do we need here
agent
bidless
task data
and matrix
okay and then we
print
from the report we probably want to
print something like
uh the
metric results
let's try
if this works
yes it actually appears to work
wow
okay now it just needs a bunch of
parameters
and
then it's cool
yay
very nice
very nice okay yeah it gets everything
correct very cool so yeah we'll just be
able to use the cli uh
um oh added eval to cli this is going to
change a little bit the eval but
i hope it's going to be useful
and that's that from me i'll just push
this as i said the repository is open
discord community is open
um
we're currently just in the beginning
stages of solving this i hope we get
farther than
the people so far
um
and get actually something to work which
would be nice
all right thank you everyone for being
here that was it
uh
just some chilling saturday afternoon
coding
and i have to do some actual work now
all right thank you very much bye